merci d'être avec nous Vincent Kapo
canela c'est de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes
sénateur de la Seine-Saint-Denis membre
du groupe Union centriste questeur du
Sénat et on va parler de votre
proposition de loi pour limiter les
perturbations lors des grèves pendant
des grèves des contrôleurs aériens mais
d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu c'est
Gabriel Attal ce matin qui dévoile son
plan de lutte contre la fraude sociale
après celui contre la fraude fiscale la
fraude sociale qui représente entre 6 et
8 milliards d'euros par an ce sont les
chiffres de la Cour des comptes et
Gabriel Attal qui veut avoir en 2027
deux fois plus de résultats qu'en 2022
alors on a vu certaines mesures il veut
mieux contrôler les allocations il faut
qu'il y ait 9 mois de résidence pour
toucher des allocations il veut
fusionner la carte Vitale avec la carte
d'identité est-ce que ce sont des
mesures que vous soutenez je crois tout
cela va dans le bon sens mon groupe lui
concentré il savait beaucoup pesé dans
ce débat depuis plusieurs années et
notamment ma collègue c'est l'intrigue
de l'ordre Nathalie Willy pour mettre en
évidence qu'il y avait quelque chose à
faire on va regarder le détail des
mesures que Monsieur Attal annonce ce
matin chez vos excellents confrères Dieu
du Parisien mais je crois que il était
temps d'avancer là-dessus ça va dans le
bon sens un contestablement il y a une
attente de nos compatriotes pour qu'il y
ait une forme d'équité fiscale sociale
également et donc nous serons forts de
proposition peut-être pourra-t-il
regarder jusqu'où on met les curseurs et
et si ce plan est suffisamment efficace
mais ça va dans le bon sens
incontestable
plus loin ou est-ce qu'il y a des choses
qui vous pèsent qui vous paraissent pas
réalistes comme fusionner la carte
vitale et la carte d'identité il y avait
eu une commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était Pascal
brindo qui était député centriste qu'il
avait présidé à ce moment-là aussi on va
regarder dans les propositions qui sont
issues du Sénat de l'Assemblée lesquels
devraient à nouveau figurer vous suivez
à attentivement les questions des
finances vous êtes membre de la
commission des finances dimanche sur
radiologie Elizabeth borne a déclaré que
le gouvernement était en discussion très
étroite avec l'agence financière
Standard zenpource au sujet de la future
note sur la dette de la France est-ce
qu'il faut craindre une dégradation de
cette note après celle déjà de pitch je
crois qu'on a une notation qui est
plutôt bonne par rapport à l'état de nos
finances aujourd'hui avec 3000 milliards
de dettes avec à peu près un tiers du
budget qui est financé par de l'emprunt
il faut en avoir conscience c'est comme
si nos compatriotes dans leur budget
finalement tous les mois devait
emprunter 30% pour assurer le
fonctionnement normal le payer des
fluides payer la nourriture etc donc on
a une vraie difficulté il est les
agences sentir les conséquences ça a
commencé avec l'une des agences je crois
pas qu'il y aura de conséquences
immédiates cela dit c'est un vrai signal
d'alarme et on doit arrêter de dépenser
autant que nous dépensons c'est une
réalité ça veut dire qu'il faut réformer
l'État ça veut dire qu'il faut parfois
aussi sur les annonces que le
gouvernement évite d'annoncer toujours
des centaines de millions et des
milliards c'est un changement de
comportement je crois et il faut se dire
que la dette commence à peser et ça fait
des années qu'elle paye donc ça va pas
durer aussi longtemps que contribution
il annonce de milliards en moins
d'impôts pour les classes moyennes d'ici
la fin du quinquennat ça il faut arrêter
ce genre de choses l'annonce en question
est une annonce gérée en bisou parce que
ça va prendre du temps tout ceci mais je
peux comprendre qu'il faille faire un
effort en direction de classe moyenne la
question c'est pouvons-nous continuer à
faire les annonces je ne le crois pas
financièrement Monsieur le Maire
d'ailleurs tient des propos qui sont
aussi parfois des signes alarmes des
signaux d'alarme pour nous dire on ne
peut pas continuer comme ça donc il
s'agit de les paroles et les actes en
cohérence là-dessus aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de dire
il faut sans doute une stabilité fiscale
et savoir qu'on peut pas payer en mon
dessin
autant de baise d'impôts et autant de
chèques oh le gouvernement n'est pas le
plus dépensé dans tout ça simplement
parce que quand je regarde les
propositions de la nups par exemple et
quand je regarde ce sont de déni de
réalité on peut se dire que le
gouvernement est plutôt vertueux mais la
question c'est une expliqué à nos
compatriotes que on a un effort à faire
produire plus dégager plus de richesse
travailler plus aussi c'est difficile
mais c'est la seule voie pour s'en
sortir d'autres pays l'ont fait on est
dans une économie ouverte et attention
simplement les taux d'intérêts ont
repris à la hausse très nettement ça
pèse sur le budget de l'État et ça veut
dire qu'à un moment donné s'il y avait
une perte de confiance bien que nous
ayons l'euro nous serions en vrai
difficulté
équilibrer nos budgets ou du moins
réduire notre endettement et notre
déficit c'est une façon de gagner la
souveraineté et préparer l'avenir on ne
peut pas faire peser sur les jeunes
générations
notre
tendance à la dépense parfois un peu
folle et ça passe aussi par la réforme
des retraites demain en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale sera examiné la
proposition de loi du groupe liote pour
abroger la réforme des retraites est-ce
que vous souhaitez qu'elle soit
examinées en séance est-ce que vous ne
souhaitez qu'il y a un vote sur ce texte
alors la tradition c'est une chambre
fait peu de commentaires sur l'autre et
je crois que ce sera au député en
fonction du règlement de la salle
nationale dans décider moi simplement ce
que je veux dire c'est que il faudra
aussi penser un jour à faire une
proposition de loi pour
abolir la TVA ou supprimer les
contributions directes aussi il faut
penser qu'on peut même passer son temps
à toujours déconstruire il y a eu un
débat certes il a été relativement mal
amené et je crois que l'explication n'a
pas été faite la réalité c'est qu'il
faut malheureusement travailler plus
c'est de l'eau pour tout le monde mais
que je n'ai fort de cohésion social pour
les jeunes générations et pour assurer
les retraites ça a été relativement
malmené en termes d'explications se
débat là maintenant le débat a eu lieu
certes il y a eu le 49-3 mais c'est la
centième utilisation du 49-3 alors moi
ce qui à la 100e fois lorsqu'ils ont eu
d'ailleurs parfois pour certains d'entre
eux une longue carrière parlementaire 40
fois ils l'ont vécu alors qu'il y a un
parlementaire se garant 9-3 et voilà la
dernière la dernière utilisation utilise
par découvrir que ça pose un problème je
crois que là-dessus il faut quand même
raison
notamment j'aime beaucoup Charles de
Courson avec qui j'ai laissé en relation
néanmoins aujourd'hui
qui a défendu à une époque la retraite à
65 ans aujourd'hui
à l'époque d'ailleurs qui est et
aujourd'hui il le retrouve attendre la
main à la news je ne comprends pas on
n'est pas obligé de tomber dans tous les
pièges de la dupesse on n'est pas obligé
de leur temps de la main il y a eu un
débat il a été tranché avec l'usage du
49-3 c'est vrai mais cet usage le
Conseil constitutionnel l'a rappelé il
est légitime la Constitution est faite
ainsi on l'a utilisé son foie il faut
savoir aussi tourner la page et en tout
cas se met dans une posture de réforme
la réforme des retraites c'est peut-être
un dixième des réformes nous avons
besoin malheureusement il faut trouver
cette équilibre là mieux qu'il n'a été
trouvé sur les retraites mais il faut se
dire que le pays doit avancer et que la
cohésion sociale suppose aussi des
réformes financières parfois
douloureuses alors la réforme de
retraite c'est dernièrement elle a
entraîné plusieurs mouvements de grève
notamment dans les aéroports français
comment limiter les perturbations pour
les passagers c'est l'objet du texte de
la proposition de loi qui serait
examinée dans quelques jours dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat on va faire le
point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alexa
[Musique]
de Vincent kapokanelas propose d'obliger
les contrôleurs aériens se déclarer 48
heures avant une grève les contrôleurs
aériens font figure d'exception parmi
les professionnels de leur secteur
individuellement un contrôleur aérien
n'est pas obligé de se déclarer pour
faire grève seuls les organisations
syndicales doivent déposer un préavis de
grève à 5 jours avant en revanche les
contrôleurs aériens doivent participer
au respect du service minimum et peuvent
donc être réquisitionnés et Alex avec ce
système actuel les grèves des
contrôleurs aériens causent de
nombreuses perturbations de trafic oui
lors de mouvement sociaux certains
contrôleur font grève sans se déclarer
en dehors des jours qui ont été annoncés
par les organisations syndicales et cela
mais la pagaille dans les aéroports
français avec des dizaines de vols
annulés par jour des retards des
correspondances à manquer résultat
depuis le début du conflit sur la
réforme des retraites et bien il y a eu
plus de 33
000 heures de cumuler dans les aéroports
français pour les passagers par exemple
une compagnie comme Ryanair a dû annuler
plus de 4000 vols depuis le début de
l'année et cette situation elle n'est
pas nouvelle déjà dans un rapport que
vous avez publié sur le sujet Vincent
apocanella et bien entre 2010 et 2016 la
France était à l'origine de 97% des
perturbations du secteur aérien de
l'Union européenne et c'est blocages ont
entraîné à l'époque des pertes
économiques de 12 milliards d'euros
alors pour remédier à cette situation la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
propose donc d'instaurer un préavis de
48 heures pour les contrôleurs et il y a
quelques mois en pleine grève contre la
réforme des retraites et bien un
sénateur avait interrogé le ministre des
Transports Clement Beaune sur cette
proposition et regardez il n'était pas
vraiment fermé même s'il voulait
privilégier le dialogue social
faut-il repenser un certain nombre de
règles ou de pratique au vu de se
comportement inattendu et inacceptable
je le crois nous regardons les choses
sans tabou d'abord la négociation
interne parce que je crois ce dialogue
social et que ce pacte jusqu'à présent
fonctionner et puis nous regarderons
avec le Parlement le cas échéant sur
l'autorité de la première ministre
l'ensemble des pistes complémentaires
dont celle que vous avez évoquée Vincent
apocanellas quelques mois plus tard
est-ce que la position du gouvernement a
évolué et favorable à votre proposition
d'instaurer un préavis de greffe pour
les contrôleurs aériens alors ma
proposition de loi elle fait suite à
d'autres tentatives et j'aborde ce sujet
avec humilité il y a eu plusieurs
tentatives qui jusque là n'ont pas
marché et d'ailleurs le président Bruno
retaillod et mon collection algériot
qu'on vient de voir passer l'antenne son
auteur de certaines de ces tentatives là
et ils sont qu'aux signataires de ma
proposition de loi c'est une démarche
nouvelle avec une rédaction qui est
différente de celle qui avait pu être
retenu à l'avance et j'espère qu'elle
fera consensus mais je suis comme tout
le monde je propose des j'ai essayé de
travailler ceci dans une optique de
dialogue social parce que je crois que
on ne réforme pas sans les
fonctionnaires qui sont concernés mais
j'attendrai que le gouvernement se
prononce en séance pour vous répondre
clairement je n'ai pas aujourd'hui de
réponse du gouvernement et je crois
quand je reprends les déclarations du
ministre et vu les contacts que j'ai eu
que en tout cas ce que je propose est
acceptable par chacune des parties je
mesure ce que ça peut représenter sa
politique je mesure que ça peut
représenter symboliquement je prends
vraiment garde à respecter le droit de
grève c'est un principe constitutionnel
il s'agit certainement pas d'altérer il
y a un service minimum mais la
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est que on
déclenche le service minimum quand il y
a un préavis et donc on abat 30% des
vols parfois il y a très peu de
grévistes et donc finalement c'est très
pénalisant parfois finalement il y a
plus de grévistes il est arrivé aussi à
l'inverse que il y ait pas d'annulation
préventive parce que le sentiment
général était qu'il y aurait peu de
grévistes et à l'arrivée on l'a vu à
Orly le 11 février beaucoup
d'annulations comme on dit à chaudes à
des moments avec des passagers des
touristes ceux qui vont pour un
déplacement de famille ou parfois un
examen médical ou autre chose qui se
retrouvent dans des moments sans avion
donc il faut réformer système quelque
part absurde et pour les passagers et
les compagnies et pour les contrôleurs
eux-mêmes qui finalement la veille
parfois vont arriver gendarme pour leur
donner une réquisition pour leur
demander d'être présent au dernier
moment donc finalement ce système est à
bout de souffle et il n'est pas
utile vous trouvez il est pas performant
ni pour les passagers ni même pour les
contrôleurs qui finalement se trouvent
des organisés vous l'avez dit presque 2
millions de minutes de retard c'est très
significatif et ça veut dire que ça peut
pas durer ça c'est juste pour la période
du conflit des retraites il y a eu 40
jours de service minimum
il faut réformer système obligé à ce que
48 heures avant on connaît le nombre de
grévistes et on a juste le trafic ma
proposition de loi vit simplement à
faire que en fonction du nombre de
grévistes le trafic soit
au niveau qui correspond à ce nombre de
grévise et pas ce système absurde il y a
peu grévistes et finalement beaucoup de
retard c'est tout la difficulté donc
finalement le dialogue social sera en
vérité ça veut dire que demain s'il y a
beaucoup d'avis il y aura beaucoup de
réduction trafic alors Ryanair qui est
la plus grosse compagnie aérienne
d'Europe qui a été qui s'estime
particulièrement lésé par ses conflits à
lancer une pétition qui a déjà été
signée par plus d'un million de
personnes elle demande un changement de
règles pour préserver le survol de la
France en permettant aux contrôleur
aérien d'autres pays de se substituer au
contrôleur français c'est une bonne
piste oh je crois que c'est un peu un
chiffon rouge qu'ils agitent et que
c'est pas la bonne démarche la bonne
démarche c'est de construire avec
l'ensemble des acteurs qui considèrent
que ce système ne marche plus ne
fonctionne plus d'abord les passagers
qui c'est vrai sont extrêmement pénalisé
et compagnie aussi mais on peut pas le
faire comme ça en agitant la controverse
les uns contre les autres et je crois
qu'il n'est pas vrai que les compagnies
qui survolent les compagnies étrangères
sont plus pénalisées il suffit de le
voir dans notre quotidien à nous voilà
ma démarche n'est pas une réponse à
Ryanair ma démarche est une réponse aux
interrogations qui remontent depuis le
début de l'année avec quelque chose qui
est très pénalisant et le trafic aérien
le contrôle aérien se modernise en ce
moment il y a un énorme effort jamais
été l'auteur ne rapporte que vous avez
ici tout à l'heure qui était très
critique sur l'évolution de ce système
là on est en train de recoller le
peloton en termes de modernisation et
aller vers des routes droites aériennes
notamment voilà ça c'est l'essentiel
là-dessus je veux dire que j'espère
qu'il y aura un consensus mais je vais
regarder je vais essayer de le
construire avec tout le monde voilà
selon vous cette situation ennuie à la
qualité des aéroports français par
rapport aux aéroports ah c'est une perte
considérable vous avez cité des chiffres
tout à l'heure je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
changé aujourd'hui on est montré du
doigt ça n'est pas compris on est dans
un système interopérable comme on dit au
niveau européen parce que lorsqu'on
avion on part de Munich par exemple ou
de Rome et qui traversent la France on
passe d'un contrôleur aérien étranger à
un contrôle aérien français et après cet
avion va continuer donc c'est un système
et aujourd'hui est obligé d'écarter les
routes pour éviter la France éviter
certains centres qui sont en grève donc
voilà il faut préserver la capacité
contrôleur et ses constitutionnels à
faire grève mais il faut aussi quelque
part entendre les droits des passagers
donc en ajoutant un service minimum qui
va être revu cet obligation c'est xareg
grévise on ajustera mieux ce sera utile
pour les passagers et je pense que aussi
les contrôleurs finalement verront un
peu leur quotidien parfois amélioré
parce que simplement aujourd'hui c'est
très erratique pour eux aussi il y a une
désorganisation totale du ciel français
tout à fait tout à fait parce que
Monsieur capo canelas vous êtes vous
êtes j'allais dire concerné à plus d'un
titre au titre de sénateur de scène
Saint-Denis qui est le département dans
lequel beaucoup de choses vont se passer
et puis commencer un maire du Bourget
qui accueillera le cluster du des médias
je crois que les équipements sont à
cheval avec la commune de Dugny
dites-nous monsieur capocana est-ce
qu'on sera prêt et vous qui est un
spécialiste des finances est-ce que vous
redoutez de nouvelles révisions à la
hausse du budget vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la hausse des taux d'intérêt
mais il y a aussi la hausse des matières
premières
alors je pense que oui on sera prêt il y
a d'énormes efforts qui ont été faits
notamment par la solideo qui construit
les ouvrages olympiques par les
collectivités locales vous avez rappelé
que à l'époque au maire du Bourget j'ai
suivi ensuite après tout ce dossier au
Bourget mais aussi dans la ville d'aduni
avec l'établissement public Paris perda
d'envol qui est l'intercommunalité et
qui nous a nous a aidé là-dessus avec le
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis on a
essayé de construire quelque chose qui
nous donne des investissements qui
soient utiles à la population notamment
et qui pense sportif parc sportifs
réaménagé les liaisons douces des
liaisons vertes voilà plus de qualité de
vie et qui aura un héritage concret des
Jeux Olympiques donc c'est toute la
démarche qu'on a construite alors ça
aurait pu peut-être être plus large dans
la Seine-Saint-Denis en tout cas on est
allé cette fois au-delà de Saint-Denis
et pleine commune qui traditionnellement
recevait ce genre d'événements donc là
c'est une façon aussi d'élargir si j'ose
dire les investissements publics à
d'autres communes donc ça avance je
crois de manière extrêmement positive à
ma connaissance solideo tient ses
engagements au budgétaires mais il
faudra évidemment
[Musique]
du salon de l'association les merdes de
France fin juin
maximiser à la fois l'héritage mais
aussi le l'engagement pendant et après
les jeux il vous semble que tout se
passe bien sur cet aspect là
c'est toujours un combat quand on est
élu local de se faire entendre de l'état
de la multiplicité d'organismes qui qui
gère ce type d'événements mais
évidemment au quotidien il y aura aussi
des perturbations il faut pas le nier
mais c'est un événement mondial
ça n'arrive qu'une fois partielle la
France a donné à voir au monde entier
qu'elle peut être aussi
une terre qui accueille de très grands
événements comme ça qui a un message je
crois que ça peut être aussi un moment
d'optimisme et que les valeurs du sport
ça compte finalement pour la jeunesse
donc il faut veiller à ce que chacun
puisse participer mais j'ai globalement
confiance dans tout ça il y a un petit
sujet quand même c'est ce sentiment que
les jeux c'est cher et notamment sur les
places je pense que ça a pas été très
bien présenté
mais c'est votre sentiment aussi il faut
des jeux plus populaires des places
moins cher je pense que tout ça
n'absence que s'il y a pas de découplage
entre le CIO le conjo d'un côté et les
territoires la population et la suite il
y a des efforts à faire oui Jacques
oui si vous permettez je voulais changer
de sujet vous venez de rencontrer le
ministre du logement et de la ville
Olivier Klein à propos des contrats de
villes je crois que vous insistez sur
l'importance de ces contrats pour la
scène Saint-Denis notamment pouvez-vous
nous en décrire un petit peu les enjeux
le plaisir de rencontrer Olivier Klein
qui est un élu d'ailleurs de mon
département qui est l'ancien maire de
Clichy-sous-Bois avec qui j'ai une
relation cordiale et qui connaît bien le
terrain qui connaît bien les sujets
politiques de la ville bien évidemment
c'est quelqu'un qui
de très longue date s'est investi
là-dedans j'avais participé à une
commission du temps de son sa
prédécesseur sur l'avenir des contrats
de ville je sais qu'il est en train d'y
réfléchir donc c'était un échange pour à
partir du terrain essayer de voir
quelles leçons pouvaient tirer la
Seine-Saint-Denis est aussi une terre
d'expérimentation sur la politique de la
ville la question là encore c'est
comment on associe les les populations
je sais que Olivier Klein il réfléchit
donc ça fait partie des axes de travail
pour pour demain mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que la politique de la ville
c'est évidemment aussi parfois de la
réparation parce qu'on a quelquefois
construit des quartiers un peu vite et
il s'agit aussi de mieux associer les
populations de soutenir la vie locale il
y a pas que l'investissement donc voilà
ça fait partie des piliers pour demain
évidemment il s'agit d'apporter les
financements qui sont attendus on est
dans une période aussi où il faut faire
attention par rapport à ça
il y a parfois des débats sur le fait
que une subvention devient récurrente et
il faut peut-être parfois examiner on
sait tous que c'est particulièrement
difficile à faire mais je souhaite que
le gouvernement avance là-dessus
à ce stade merci beaucoup une journal du
Grand Paris alors Paris face au défi
écologique et social c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup merci
Jacques paquet d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin on va parler des sénatoriales
puisque la Seine-Saint-Denis fait partie
des départements renouvelables est-ce
que vous serez candidat à votre
succession à 180
électeurs de la Seine-Saint-Denis dans
quelques temps le moment n'est pas
encore n'est pas encore venu voilà je
souhaite rester actif au service du
département au service des collectivités
on vient de le voir à l'instant en
première couronne en Seine-Saint-Denis
il y a beaucoup d'enjeux pour l'avenir
il s'agit de défendre nos territoires et
de faire que on puisse inscrire
véritablement dans ce Grand Paris qui se
construit à la métropole il y a les
territoires c'est parfois un contexte
difficile il faudra revenir aussi sur
cette équilibre institutionnel trop de
complexité c'est ce que me disent les
îles locaux voilà j'aurais à cœur
devrait devrait dans ce sens là
des villes qui ont été perdus par les
centrices aux dernières municipales
notamment Bobigny notamment Drancy
est-ce que c'est possible pour les
centrices de garder un siège il y a des
villes qui ont été gagnées je pense
notamment à Aubervilliers voilà il y a
des villes qui sont passées aussi de
logique très partisanes entre guillemets
à des logiques disons de droite modérée
divers droites etc on travaille tous
ensemble on travaille ici pour défendre
le département pour être au service de
tous c'est en tout cas ma démarche et je
pense qu'elle réussira ce sera si vous y
allez mais en tout cas on sent votre
envie de rentrer d'un côté
droit on va pas politiser les choses les
configurations seront reconnues bientôt
on a une logique de diversité et
d'addition
sur justement puisqu'on parle des
républicains il y a un sujet qui
peut-être vous allez nous le dire risque
de diviser la majorité sénatorielle
c'est la question de l'immigration ce
week-end dans le Parisien Gérald
Darmanin n'a pas exclu un texte commun
entre les républicains et le
gouvernement à condition qu'il soit
discuté avec les centrices ça vous
paraît possible je trouve que c'est
pragmatique une bonne chose Hervé
Marseille a annoncé je crois que c'était
sur le site du Journal du Dimanche hier
qu'il y aurait des propositions qui
seraient faites notamment mon collègue
Philippe bonne Carrère travaille sur ces
propositions là on aura aussi notre mot
à dire dans ce qu'il faut trouver le
symptôme de la division de la droite et
du centre sur cette question de
l'immigration pourquoi les centrées se
font des propositions à part celle des
républicains vous conviennent pas mais
pourquoi nous n'en ferions pas chaque
formation politique est appelée à faire
acte de proposition là-dessus il faut
trouver un équilibre le gouvernement
avait un texte il a commencé à être
examiné par la commission des Lois du
Sénat et puis ça s'est arrêté ça reprend
une forme de tango il s'agit d'être
responsable on peut pas laisser ce sujet
tel quel et on peut pas laisser les
extrêmes aussi sans saisir en disant
regardez la classe politique n'est pas
capable de trouver des solutions et de
réformer je pense qu'il faut des mesures
fortes mais équilibrées c'est-à-dire
vers Marseille simplement c'est que on
peut pas uniquement aussi
vouloir changer la constitution ce qui
serait très long ce qui remettrait à
très longtemps et qui vous trouve
peut-être dans le champ actuel des
textes une possibilité d'avancer c'est
ça notre démarche pragmatique donc c'est
à dire pas la proposition
constitutionnelle des républicains mais
la proposition doit ordinaire celle
qu'il reprend en grande partie les
propositions du rapport de France annuel
buffet ça là vous la soutenez je pense
que la proposition de l'eau a
constitutionnelle pour être examinée
mais il faut avoir une majorité 3/5 en
l'état actuel à l'Assemblée je vois mal
comment on peut progresser on va
regarder alors sur l'autre partie sur
les questions d'immigration c'est le
droit national qui doit primer sur le
droit européen est-ce que ça c'est
quelque chose auquel vous pouvez adhérer
je crois qu'il y a un sentiment de perte
de contrôle de nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent que l'entrée le séjour des
populations étrangères en France soit
mieux contrôler et que ça il faut y
répondre clairement il faut aussi se
dire que on a un devoir collectif
l'intégration je pense que nos
compatriotes qui sont issus de
l'immigration sont les premiers aussi à
souhaiter que chacun puisse vivre
ensemble en respectant nos coutumes et
que ça se construit ensemble donc ça
c'est l'essentiel il faut revenir à ça
après attention à pas ouvrir tous les
sujets en même temps soyons pragmatique
trouvons des solutions merci non c'est
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin dans 20 minutes dans le
club des territoires on dévoilera le
baromètre au doxa pour publique Senna et
la presse régionale notamment sur votre
perception des violences faites aux élus
et sur la réponse apportée par le
gouvernement est-elle la bonne on verra
ce que vous en pensez mais d'abord on va
reparler la réforme des retraites avec
notre invité Bertrand pencheres